[Music]
by joining us now in studio responding
to all this breaking news is president
Trump's attorney we're do Giuliani mr.
mayor good to see you sir how are you
good to see you let's start with
tonight's breaking news he got or steal
Nelly or you got Russian lies kind of
get any worse I mean what do we need to
know that this is a totally illegitimate
investigation based on a report a
dossier that was paid for by Hillary
Clinton and the Democrats probably the
biggest illegality so far the biggest
collusion so far or conspiracy
completely made-up completely made-up
led to nothing except several fraudulent
Pfizer wires and now we have Muller who
doesn't seem to care that he's sitting
on top of a totally illegitimate
investigation but the thing about the
dossier that she paid for and the fact
that the FBI paid steel it was designed
to miss inform the American people with
Russian lies to influence the election
yes there's a great irony here if it
wasn't well maybe it maybe maybe if
Muller and his band of of whatever they
are Democrats right we're fair-minded
maybe they'd investigate maybe that's
the collusion maybe that's the collusion
did you ever hear the Adam Schiff tape
that we played yes Adam Schiff he's just
dying to get naked pictures of Trump
with a Russian on tape there's your
evidence more you can't make it up I
mean if it if it wasn't so seriously not
only did they try to lie to the American
people with Russian lies now we know
after the election they tried to destroy
the president with lies and now they're
connected to Muller perhaps I've that
I've never been involved in an
investigation on either side that's more
illegitimate than this one that is so
obviously more illegitimate and I wonder
where's the sense of justice on the part
of Muller on the part of the Justice
Department after all the Justice
Department this is a Justice Department
investigation he's working for
Rosenstein and at some point he got to
say the irregularities the
in ethical conduct double standard
double standard the way in which people
who hate Trump will put into primary
positions of power has completely
tainted this investigation as a family
from law enforcement my mom was a prison
guard you know my dad New York City
Family Court probation or so many cops
of my family FBI agents I I cannot
believe this is such a user the rank and
file are so good here's the thing you
responded today to Muller's latest
request and you said think this could be
over by September let's start with the
well I think if it isn't over by
September then we have a very very
serious violation of the Justice
Department rules then you shouldn't be
conducting one of these investigations
in the 60-day period rookies got plenty
of time
to either decide but we offered him an
opportunity to do a form of questioning
he can say yes or no we can do it if you
doesn't want to do it he knows the
answers to every question that he wants
to ask he's gonna ask him did you tell
call me to go easy on Flint the
president said no I didn't hey Bob you
know it wait why do you want to get him
under oath you think we're fools they
want to get him on the rope cause you
want to trap him into perjury but we're
not gonna let you do that
it's there's two separate issues
collusion and so-called obstruction
there's a report today you said no
questions on obstruction am i assuming
here that you're that your response to
him was maybe a couple of written
answers only I can't tell you what it is
yet because we haven't jail get very
honestly my co-counsel I understand much
stricter about this than I am so he'll
get very angry and Jane will I'd love to
tell you but the reality is the reality
is he doesn't need to ask a single
question on obstruction he has all the
answers they're not gonna change the
president's not gonna change his
testimony so stop the nonsense you are
trying to trap him into perjury because
you don't have a case mr. mayor the
Constitution is our good friend Marxist
mark levin is on the president's side
the I agree it's illegitimate has been
the double standard is so glaring we
have been poor
it out now every night and with new
details every night my question is I
wouldn't give him a thing you don't owe
him a thing and if he wants a fight then
it's gonna be a fight well we don't like
to fight you know that I used to watch
your press conferences I disagree the
reality is the real story here is not
that this case isn't gonna fizzle it's
gonna blow up on them the real question
is what we talked about before there's a
lot more to what they did they nobody
knows about yet I know a lot more to the
obstruction of justice to the collusion
to the fate dust all wide no Ryan of
being sealed back in after he was
completely discredited and then feed it
to Muller yeah and Muller is gonna have
a lot to answer for mr. mayor I said a
long time ago the investigation here has
to be in the investigators because we
can't let this happen again in American
history we may not have a president as
strong as President Trump the Alessa
president could have really been cracked
by this Muller then you got Jeanie ray
you got Andrew Weissman here's my
question
we know the Department of Justice has
absolutely denied congressional
subpoenas now I don't because great a
lawyer as you are I don't think you'd
get me out of trouble if I was ignoring
a subpoena no I'm good but the president
has the power to go through these
documents through the FISA and onward
make it unredacted and let the American
people see that the bulk of information
was what Christopher steel himself said
that something wasn't verified something
that as his private lawyers that that he
has to do with Emmett and and and his
government lawyers and I he's going to
do suggest he should I can't tell you
what I suggest is it privilege privilege
okay let me ask you about the FISA lies
the bulk of information the Grassley
gram memo says came from the phony
dossier that Hillary paid for that turns
out to be a lie the author of it says he
can't corroborate it now here's a month
question so they used the four separate
times to spy out an American citizen an
opposition party candidate campaign
associate
the lead-up to the election after the
election again what if I lied to a judge
I wouldn't think of lying to a judge
without my life in jail after we
investigated for perjury you've been
investigating for contempt your career
would be ruined
you'll likely be ruined and and I
believe that when this plays out over
the next year or two it's not gonna be
about President Trump it's gonna get
over with it's gonna be about all the
things they did this this you know how
sometimes that the cover-up is worse
than the crime in this case the
investigation was much worse than the no
crime mr. mayor basically did nothing
wrong my sources are telling me that
when the American people get to the
bottom of all of this it will shock the
heart the soul and the mind of any
fair-minded American I think it's gonna
lead to some very strict very big
reforms just like Watergate it's a
different kind of Watergate it's on your
side of the investigator okay corrupt
investigations through and through why
would you even consider a
counterproposal when it's over with I'll
expose you I'm not getting anything out
of you tonight good to see you mr. mayor
thank you